- [Instructor] So the
first thing you want to do
is go to your App Store and
download Khan Academy Kids.
Once you've done that,
you can open our app,
and you'll be greeted
by our fun characters,
Cody, Orlov, Sandy, Raya and Peck.
You'll be taken to a signup
screen, click Sign up
and enter your email.
We use this email to create your account,
and we're going to ask you to verify it.
So once you've entered
it and clicked next,
you'll receive an email
in your email inbox.
And you want to click the verify
email button in that email,
and then you're set to
go back into the app
and start creating accounts for your kids.
Click next here, and here you are.
First we're going to add the
name of our first child Kim.
Kim is six, and we'll select
an avatar for Kim, a dolphin.
Ready to start learning now,
but we'll quickly show you
how to create a profile for another child.
If you swipe up into the parent section,
you'll see Kim's account
there, tap the new button,
swipe up, and enter the name
of the next child, Oscar.
Oscar is actually older, he's seven
and he is going to be a tiger.
And now we have two children's
profiles, Kim and Oscar.
We're going to start learning
with Kim so we tap Kim,
and if we press the play button,
he will be in our
personalized learning path.
It will serve up age
appropriate activities
for your child like this one.
- (Character) And together
they have five toy dinosaurs.
- If you wanted to do self serve,
you could click in the top left
corner on the library icon.
Then you can scroll through
all of our activities,
books, videos, our reading, our logic,
social emotional learning,
and you can pick out
what your child works on.
We've partnered with National Geographic
and Bellwether Media to
offer a range of characters
and stories and formats
to keep your child busy.
And there's always the
offline functionality,
that suitcase under the word library.
We can't wait for you to discover
everything there is to do
on Khan Academy Kids.